[Applause]
making buckets
is brought to you by kfc devon booker's
making buckets throughout these playoffs
and as you see most points in his first
nba playoffs
he's obviously played more games than
rick barry and dr j did
but he has been magnificent remember he
had 47 points
in the clincher against the lakers in
the first round the western conference
finals had that 40 point triple double
in game one and he is just sparkling
tonight 32 points in 29 minutes
as middleton hits the free throw however
his son's just
up by two think about the company that
that graphic hat on there that's rick
barry and dr jeff boss they were up by
seven points with four to play trae
young had 48
only time they've been defeated in this
postseason
[Applause]
[ __ ] first shot of the night
milwaukee scored 120 points in game
three as booker's floater is good
he's one of the all-time greats in terms
of assisted turnover ratio booker
second chance back up and in an
aggressive devin booker
already with six points
[Applause]
meanwhile 8-0 run by milwaukee they've
got a four-point lead
booker knocks it down seven boards for
eight
[Applause]
booker left-handed coach i like the idea
of the phoenix suns running action
for devin booker putting him in position
to be aggressive as a scorer
comes off the screen downhill the size
of brook lopez and the ability
next two games 25 and 31. he said
booker bounced back games in these
playoffs leans in left-handed bags at
home
holiday now on booker kevin booker puts
it in
tough shot from booker he's got 16. so
not allowing him this route it opens up
other
things but right now he's got a rhythm
on that play
what you mean for those
[Music]
[Applause]
booker one on one spins
falling away in the baseline it's got a
tough shot from devin booker
backing in against a very strong
pat connaughton spins baseline
taking a little bump a slap by giannis
and a hoop
[Music]
[Applause]
booker
picks up booker left-handed once again
well three of devin booker's 10 made
field goals tonight have been with his
left hand
that's a wrong foot get it up quick
before the shot blocker comes over
in brook lopez that's exquisite touch
you guys might be too young to remember
the great larry bird scoring 40-plus
points against the portland trailblazer
ollie trying to poke it away and hari
just so strong
hooker with four to shoot drives getting
inside spins falling away
it's good and then blocking the layup
attack
this is a tough physical grinding game
yeah there's just a lot more contact
allowed
in this series as booker not allowing
the
direct line drive to the cup hooker back
in playing with the four fouls
one-on-one with conaton
one of the greatest passing forwards
you'll ever see
[Music]
five to shoot booker steps back
okay like mark says sounds good
booker against holiday gets inside flips
it up flips it in
evan [ __ ] putting out a show here in
the third quarter
he's exploded here in this third period
seven for seven from the field
[Music]
and the bucks go up by two
great play by giannis to trust
connington in that situation
hooker the drive booker the pull up and
he banks it
an 8-0 chris middleton run six-point
lead
booker the drive gets inside backs it
home with 14.7 remaining